das darf man sich gar nicht ausmalen und
deswegen muss man sagen weil sie haben
ja auch gerade kritisch polizisten
angesprochen dass wir jetzt eben auf der
anderen seite auch einfach mal danke
schön sagen wir sind für das was die
polizei gestern geleistet hat ganz
besonders natürlich die die 3d quasi als
letzte linie den mob vom reichstag vom
eindringenden reichstag ferngehalten
haben ich glaube das war eine ganz
großartige leistung kollege von mir aus
bayern martin hagen hat ja heute schon
bei ihnen vorgeschlagen denen das
bundesverdienstkreuz zu erkennen ich
glaube das wäre tatsächlich eine gute
maßnahme aber wir müssen natürlich auch
in aller deutlichkeit sagen das ist hier
von der einsatzleitung und vom land
berlin massive defizite gegeben hat das
darf natürlich auch nicht passieren es
ist ja im vorfeld von einem sturm auf
berlin im netz mit dem hashtag sturm auf
berlin von radikalen kreisen geworben
worden und insofern musste waren auch
damit rechnen dass es möglicherweise
solche versuchen